avec vous julien shahida bonjour julien
jean paul n y aura-t-il de l'électricité
et du gaz pour tous à l'hiver la
question continue julien à d'agiter les
partenaires européens qui multiplient
les réunions pour tenter de pallier à la
fin de l'approvisionnement en gaz russe
effectivement pauline il faut bien
s'imaginer que depuis plusieurs jours
plusieurs semaines ça fourmille à
bruxelles dans le quartier européen
d'allées et venues de ministres de
secrétaires d'état à la recherche d'un
consensus pour éviter une crise
énergétique majeure ça bouillonne
racontera la croix le commissaire
européen thierry breton dernière
proposition vous disiez mettre en commun
des stocks de gaz et d'électricité en
cas de difficultés c'est en tout cas ce
que souhaite faire la france et
l'allemagne une solidarité européenne
très appréciable en théorie personne ne
leur reprochera sauf comme le rappelle
l'humanité si cela doit se faire aux
dépens du climat car la france avec la
moitié de son parc nucléaire à l'arrêt
ne pourra donc produire l'électricité
dont elle a besoin cet hiver alain
n'emportera d'allemagne sauf que en
échange de gaz français sauf que cette
électricité pauline est tout sauf
propres regardez ces nuages noirs qui
sortent des cheminées de centrales à
charbon allemandes dans l'urgence
bernard n'a pas d'autre choix que de
redémarrer 27 de ses vieilles centrales
à charbon qu'elle avait d'ores et déjà
fait 1 mais récemment mais il n'y a pas
qu'en france et où en allemagne que le
marché l'électricité est très tendue oui
effectivement chez notre voisin suisse
il n'y a pas de problème
d'approvisionnement pour l'instant en
revanche le pays n'échappe pas à la
hausse du coût de l'électricité + 27 %
par rapport à l'année dernière
conséquence les toits de l'état doit
venir en aide financièrement à l'un des
principaux acteurs du secteur explique
le journal le temps un crédit de 4
milliards de francs suisses qui fait
grincer de l'autre côté des alpes on
prend la direction d'un crime est à
présent au la guerre en ukraine
n'empêche pas les russes d'aller
profiter des températures douces de
cette faune est effectivement c'est
l'été indien mabide sont même encouragés
à le faire car il n'y a aucun danger je
cite pour les vacanciers d'après les
propos de cet homme le gouverneur
autoproclamé de la péninsule au
quotidien russe izvestia
pas question pour lui de mettre fin à la
saison touristique plutôt prévu dit il
la sécurité renforcée le risque est
mineur et l'eau potable ne manque plus
assure-t-il l'été indien donc se
poursuit en crimée merci qui merci aux
retraités ironise le site internet de la
radio free europe alors que les bombes
pleuvent à quelques centaines de
kilomètres de là ces touristes n'avait
pas du tout l'intention de sacrifier
leurs traditionnelles vacances d'été en
crimée s'indigne le journaliste il
rappelle tout de même que même si les
combats sont lointains la guerre est
bien présente sur la péninsule avec la
présence notamment de dizaines de
centaines de blindés russes encore
aperçu récemment encore avec des vols
d'avions de chasse à très basse altitude
voilà est-ce qu'on voit derrière vous il
s'agit d'un montage bien sûr à 500 km de
là julien là on en parlait dans le
journal avec gulli vers craag la
situation à la centrale nucléaire de
zappos ridja est toujours très critique
oui le secrétaire général de l'onu
dénonce des attaques inacceptables à
propos à proximité de la plus grande
centrale nucléaire d'europe ils
réclament une zone spéciale de sûreté
autour de la zone après notamment le
rapport des inspecteurs du l'iowa qui
décrit une situation je suis extrêmement
précaires intenable avec encore ces
derniers jours des bombardements survenu
tout près du site nucléaire
une ombre à présent qui plane sur un
tout autre sujet sur le paris saint
germain on parle de football après les
propos peu amènes de l'entraîneur des
parisiens sur les déplacements de son
équipe oui la question est simple les
footballeurs doivent-ils prendre le
train au lieu de l'avion lorsque la
distance à parcourir pour leur équipe
est courte une simple question qui avait
été posée à christophe galtier
l'entraîneur du paris saint germain est
une réponse qui a mis le feu aux poudres
plutôt le char à voile que le train
évidemment il s'agissait d'une blague
qui n'a pas plu du tout hors sol
irrespectueux et irresponsables
les critiques ont fusé de toute part
notamment de matignon encore hier soir
sur le manque de responsabilité de
l'équipe parisienne sur les questions
environnementales
l'entraîneur sait depuis hier soit
excusé pour ce qu'il appelle une
mauvaise blague mais la question est
aussi est ce que foutent et écologie ça
peut aller ensemble eh bien oui explique
libération en espagne le club du betis
séville club de première division a
signé un accord avec la compagnie
ferroviaire nationale pour ses
déplacements en train normal ou en tgv
quand c'est nécessaire et le le
quotidien rappelle que ça n'a pas
d'incidence sur les résultats sportifs
puisque l'année dernière le betis a
remporté la coupe d'espagne et puis côté
terrain pour le coup on n'oubliera pas
la victoire du psg hier face à la juge
de but 1 avec un doublé de m bape et à
propos de stars et des toiles julien on
va prendre la direction de l'espace avec
la toute dernière image du télescope
james webb elle est magnifique expliquez
nous ce qu'on voit alors des couleurs
orangées avec des nuances de beige
englobant une centaine zone centrale
noir juste au centre voici la toute
dernière photo du télescope spatial
james webb et on appelle cela en langage
cosmique une tarentule cosmique à cause
de ces longs filaments de poussière une
image qui s'étend même quand même sur
340 années-lumière encore jamais
observée jusqu'à présent merci beaucoup